madame la première ministre notre groupe
politique a fait de la baisse des prix à
la pompe une priorité absolue face à la
formule est des prix des carburants
grâce à notre mobilisation sans faille
nous et oui c'est bien nous les
républicains qui avons obtenu de réelles
avancées pour les français en obtenant
une ristourne de l'état de 30 centimes
par litre contre 10,8 au début et une
remise de 20 centimes de total soit une
baisse de 50 centimes par litre de
carburant à la pompe qui sera effective
dès septembre j'ajoute également les 230
millions d'euros de l'aide pour les
ménages qui se chauffent au fioul et les
15 millions d'euros de soutien aux
stations service en milieu rural je le
dis haut et fort il est vital de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat à tous les
français je pense en particulier aux
habitants dans nos territoires ruraux
asphyxié par l'inflation et des taxes
record ils souffrent plus spécifiquement
cependant ces mesures vont dans le bon
sens ne sont qu'un début elle ne saurait
être suffisante sur le long terme seriez
vous donc prête madame la première
ministre a baissé de manière pérenne les
taxes sur les carburants comme nous vous
le demandons depuis plusieurs semaines
déjà enfin alors que la ristourne à la
pompe doit s'arrêter en fin d'année
pouvez-vous clairement nous garantir
qu'elle sera prolongée si les prix du
pétrole ne baisse toujours pas d'ici là
je vous remercie